Trascrizione: TED Translators admin
Revisore: Alessandra Tadiotto
L'idea che vi presento
in realtà è qualcosa che
si può mettere in pratica perché
noi stiamo sprecando tanto, tantissimo,
forse troppo e non ce ne rendiamo conto.
Vi darò qualche dato,
ma prima vi faccio vedere cosa si spreca.
Prendete uno yogurt
(io sono un grande consumatore di yogurt).
Andate a far la spesa con questo carello
che, fra l'altro,
voi non ne ve ne rendete conto
ma va per conto suo.
C'è uno strano motore che è dentro,
invisibile,
e vi porta lui tra gli scaffali.
Non siete voi che lo spingete.
Però quando avete bisogno
di uno yogurt,
magari l'avete in lista,
avete questo scaffale che vi è davanti,
voi guardate,
state molto attenti alla scadenza
E cosa fate, lo vede li
altezza vostra occhi, guardate,
oddio mi scade fra due giorni
quindi se me lo porto a casa cosa succede?
Magari lo mangio
alla quarantanovesima ora.
Quindi avete un braccio
abbastanza lungo,
dita retrattili -
la natura ci ha fatto così -
e prendete lo yogurt che scade dopo.
Lo mettete... dopo
vuol dire tra una settimana o 10 giorni
lo mettete nel vostro carrello,
continuate il giro
state molto attenti a seguire la lista
però siete un po' attirati
perché ce il 2x3 il 3x4
e via con le tabelline.
Riempite, riempite questo carrello.
Dopodiché lui vi porta alla fine,
perché alla fine c'è l'acqua minerale
che voi avete in lista
e però non avete più spazio,
avete paura di riempirla
e quindi la prendete,
prendete... un otre
no? una gerla? con una mano,
l'altra con l'altra mano
e fate fare all'acqua minerale
l'ultimo miglio fino a casa vostra
spingendo probabilmente
col mento perché non avete più le mani.
Beh questo gesto, questo dello yogurt,
dell'acqua minerale
quello di acquistare e di riempire tanto
ci porta in realtà a sprecare.
Quello yogurt che avete lasciato lì
in realtà nessuno lo prende
perché nessuno ci casca.
Anzi, i direttori dei supermercati
a furia di sentirmi
adesso state attenti,
perché rimescolano tutto,
magari vi mettono lo yogurt
che scade dopo davanti.
Qual è il problema?
Che questo yogurt non ancora scaduto
in realtà viene tolto da qualcuno,
si chiama "descaffalatore",
è una persona molto importante per noi,
e lo porta poi dove
è arrivato e li muore,
con tutti i suoi fermenti lattici,
determinando però
dei costi per la società.
Un costo economico,
intanto è una mancata vendita,
poi smaltire costa.
È anche un costo ambientale,
perché a smaltire si inquina.
Beh, a una primaria società italiana
che produce yogurt
questo giochino costa
qualcosa come 20 milioni di euro,
che noi poi ci ritroviamo
da qualche parte.
Allora a furia di sommare yogurt
abbiamo calcolato -
e fa parte della campagna
"Un Anno Contro lo Spreco"
vogliamo sapere quanto
si getta via di yogurt,
di pasta, avete presente
questa pasta secca?
C'è scritto "da consumarsi
preferibilmente entro".
Non è una scadenza come lo yogurt
che ha dei fermenti lattici vivi
poi si può andare
anche un poco oltre in realtà
però forse è meglio
non dirlo in tutto il mondo.
Ma qui quando avete una scadenza
e si dice "da consumarsi
entro una certa data"
in reltà è una scelta commerciale,
perché spaghetti di marche
diverse scadono in periodi diversi.
Si vuole ruotare gli scaffarli.
Ve li portate a casa ed è una,
forse, della maggiori cause di spreco
perché il consumatore
ha sempre paura, sempre di più
e questa paura lo porta
a buttare via anche
il prodotto che
potrebbe essere consumato
questo si tranquillamente
anche per legge.
Allora noi abbiamo sommato mele, pere
yogurt, pasta, scatolette danneggiate
e abbiamo visto che in un anno in Italia
nel nostro paese si gettano
via qualcosa come,
in valore, 11 miliardi di euro.
È una manovra finanziaria.
È lo 0,72% del Prodotto Interno Lordo,
questo indicatore che misura,
per la verità,
soltanto l'accumulo
della nostra ricchezza.
Ma questa è poverta,
perché noi gettiamo via
questi prodotti che abbiamo prodotto
usando delle risorse limitate,
non scarse, non infinite, limitate:
il suolo, l'acqua, l'energia.
Poi abbiamo usato altre risorse,
visto che li abbiamo prodotti,
trasformati, trasportati, distribuiti
e non consumati,
altre risorse per distruggerli.
Lasciamo delle tracce,
si chiamano...
l'impronta ecologica:
il territorio, appunto, che usiamo,
le risorse che usiamo, l'impronta idrica,
l'acqua che abbiamo usato per produrre,
trasformare e distribuire.
Non soltanto quella dello spreco.
Abbiamo lasciato delle tracce
di anidride carbonica, tante,
inquinamento e così via.
Allora, non vi sembra assurdo
questo sistema
che accumula, e il carrello
è un po' la metafora
della nostra vita, questo carrello
che corre fra gli scaffali,
e poi in realtà [crea]
inquinamento, i costi economici
i costi sociali.
Non vi sembra un po' assurdo
questo sistema?
A me pare di si.
Allora noi abbiamo fatto due cose,
due idee che si sono materializzate
fra le tante - le idee sono poi infinite:
a me vengono a mitraglia,
però poi le devi realizzare
altrimenti non sono tali, non sono idee.
La prima è stata: ma perché
non riusciamo a recuperare questo yogurt?
Quando io l'ho visto dietro le quinte
pronto per essere distrutto
con i suoi fermenti lattici,
io che sono un grande
consumatore di yogurt
ho detto: "ma non ci sarà qualcuno,
visto che questo ha perso
il suo valore economico,
il suo valore commerciale,
ma io so che se lo apro nelle 48 ore
ha tutti i suoi fermenti e quindi
lo posso mangiare tranquillamente?
Non ci sarà qualcuno
che lo può consumare?"
Si, c'è.
E da quando abbiamo avuto questa idea
e a metterla in pratica, questo qualcuno
lo abbiamo chiamato
"consumatore senza potere d'acquisto".
È un povero, un indigente,
un escluso, è in aumento.
E quindi non abbiamo fatto altro -
si chiama Last Minute Market,
Mercato dell'Ultimo Minuto,
è uno spin-off,
una società vera e propria
dell'Università di Bologna -
abbiamo detto, forse noi riusciamo
ad incrociare
questa offerta potenziale
(è un prodotto che
viene gettato via questo
ma io ti dimostro
che è ancora consumabile)
con una domanda potenziale.
Un'offerta e una domanda,
che poi sono due persone in qualche modo,
potenziali e siccome siamo all'università
abbiamo detto
"Ma è facile da fare,
sono due meno. Meno e meno fa più".
Ma non rendeva molto.
Siccome io sono un economista,
seppure di campagna, di campo
ho detto ai ragazzi
che lavorano con me,
che sono molto più attivi,
"Beh, facciamo uno scambio, un baratto!
Diamo lo yogurt a qualcuno...
beh però non ha niente da darci in cambio.
Allora facciamo uno scambio
senza contropartita, te lo do e basta".
Non funziona molto bene.
Insomma, bello essere all'univeristà
perché chiedi
"ma come facciamo" a qualche antropologo
che ti dice "creiamo una relazione,
uno scambio di anime".
Le anime? Ho detto, questo cosa c'entra?
C'è un donatore,
uno che ha un'eccedenza, un surplus
e un donatario.
Chi è il donatario?
"Il beneficiario" mi ha detto.
Ah, capisco un po' meglio:
quello che ha una carenza, un deficit.
Allora incrociamoli in qualche modo,
ed è potentissimo.
Perché recuperando questo yogurt,
che passa effettivamente
da una mano all'altra,
in uno spazio ridottissimo
(mercato dell'ultimo minuto,
anche se non c'è il prezzo c'è il dono
potente, molto potente).
Effettivamente crei una relazione
che va oltre quel recupero.
Intanto allunghi la vita dello yogurt,
dei suoi poveri fermenti, da una parte.
Poi allunghi la vita di chi lo consuma,
che non potrebbe acquistarlo.
Ma sopratutto crei una relazione
fra chi dona e chi riceve,
che sono due persone.
Un'impresa "for profit",
quella che vende lo yogurt e un ente
"no profit" caritativo, quello che
lo riceve per nutrire gli indigenti.
Si chiama "valore di relazione",
molto potente.
Ti fa vedere che dentro
l'economia che fallisce
( lo spreco è un fallimento di mercato, costa)
c'è anche l'antidoto
in qualche modo, c'è la soluzione.
È l'economia del dono.
Io pensavo, da economista,
seppur applicato,
di quelli che guardano dal basso all'alto,
che crescono le piante,
ho detto "ma questo è un ossimoro,
una contraddizione in termine.
No. O è economia, o è dono, è gratis!".
No. Esiste in realtà, perché crea
una relazione, un valore di relazione.
Che va oltre il bene stesso,
che intanto è recuperato.
E che è fra due persone,
che è quello che ci manca poi, in realtà,
in questa società chiusa
che ha paura di tutto,
dello yogurt e dei suoi fermenti lattici.
Però per uscire da
questa logica della carità
della solidarietà, che pure è importante,
della relazione che ti fa vedere
che un altro mondo è possibile
che esiste un'altra economia,
che non c'è solo
il valore di scambio,
produci, vendi, acquisiti,
il valore d'uso, mangi, bevi, ti vesti,
ma c'è anche il valore
di relazione tra le persone.
Però poi, alla fine, veniva fuori
"Ma guarda i ragazzi dell'università
hanno fatto una società,
aiutano i poveretti".
E via! Sprechiamo pure,
allora, a questo punto!
Perché tanto c'è qualcuno che recupera.
Allora il mondo sta andando avanti
su due binari paralleli.
Come quelle convergenze che una volta,
ai bei tempi della politica,
quando c'era la politica,
ogni tanto, si univano.
Da una parte aumentano
gli sprechi, le inefficienze.
Abbiamo costruito una società
che usa e getta
che ha l'obsolescenza programmata.
I beni, compresi il cibo, vale poco.
Ad un certo punto si esauriscono,
non funzionano più,
non sono più mangiabili.
Oppure percepita: pensate alla moda.
E quindi noi dobbiamo produrre, produrre,
acquistare, acquistare
poi sprecare o rifiutare,
nel bidone della spazzatura,
altra carta d'intentità dell'italiano.
Su 550 kg di prodotti che
noi gettiamo via (rifuto solido urbano)
il 20% è già l'imballaggio.
Noi arriviamo a casa, stipiamo tutto nel nostro frigorifero
(apritelo stasera, la tomba dello spreco)
ci sono gli imballaggi.
E poi da un terzo ad un quarto sono beni,
io lo chiamo ancora così,
ancora consumabili o utilizzabili.
Beh, c'è qualcosa che
non funziona, per l'appunto.
Un binario, una rotaia che corre
e dall'altra parte aumentano gli affamati.
Ma non in Africa,
come noi pensiamo, ma qui!
A Bologna, in Italia,
nei paesi sviluppati, aumentano.
Allora noi cosa facciamo?
La traversina:
due rotaie che corrono veloci
e tante traversine, perché c'è
Last Minute Market
ed "n" progetti ed iniziative
che si occupano di recuperare.
Ma il messaggio non può essere questo:
sprecate pure, tanto c'è qualcuno
che recupera ... no!
Il sistema non funziona,
vogliamo riequilibrarlo?
Allora abbiamo lanciato questa campagna
che si chiama
"Un Anno Contro lo Spreco - 2010".
Non avevamo interlocutori nazionali
allora abbiamo pensato
"rivolgiamoci all'Europa"
Ci hanno ascoltato,
è stato importante.
Abbiamo portato quelle dichiarazioni
che fanno un pò gli universitari,
la società civile:
"Vogliamo ridurre gli sprechi del 50%
da qui al 2025 con azioni concrete?"
2025 perché il 2020, sapete,
in Europa è molto impegnato
quindi siamo andati un pò oltre.
Però proponendo tutta una serie di iniziative
che prevengono gli sprechi!
Che rendono il sistema
un pò più efficiente.
Perché lo spreco è rifiuto,
poi in realtà,
rifiuto delle persone,
rifiuto dei beni, inquinamento.
Stiamo tutti peggio, in realtà.
Allora ci hanno ascoltato
e hanno iniziato a lavorare,
io pensavo che a livello di Parlamento
Europeo non fossero poi così impegnati,
hanno preso questi 10 punti
della dichiarazione
e hanno detto "Beh, però".
Hanno cominciato a emettere
degli emendamenti,
degli altri punti ed è venuta fuori
una Risoluzione del Parlamento Europeo
votata da tutti, poi.
Perché il problema ce l'abbiamo tutti.
Vi darò qualche numero globale,
lo dico subito:
a livello mondiale sprechiamo
1,3 miliardi di tonnellate di cibo
nella filiera agroalimentare,
da un terzo a un quarto!
Fino, in alcuni casi, anche ad un mezzo.
E se trasformassimo tutto in nutrienti
quello che gettiamo via,
oltre il costo ambientale,
potremmo dare da mangiare a 3 miliardi,
poco meno della metà
della popolazione mondiale.
C'eè qualcosa che non va in effetti.
Bene, questi punti che vengono proposti,
fra cui anche la richiesta
dell'Anno Europeo 2014
per la riduzione degli sprechi,
sono molto concreti, riguardano tutti noi.
Tutti noi consumatori, ma tutta la filiera.
Allora quello yogurt,
ma perché non ce lo ritroviamo al 50%?
Così sarà un rifiuto in meno e sarà anche
non solo una misura antispreco,
questo sconto
che potrebbe farci
la grande distribuzione,
ma anche anticrisi,
perché c'è un consumatore
che lo compra al 50%.
Poi dopo averlo pagato
si metterà li col cucchiaino
e lo consumerà subito, per paura che
questi benedetti fermenti lattici,
lo dico, così, perché la domanda
mi sembra dai vostri occhi
che me la state per fare,
questi fermenti lattici
dalla 48esima alla 49esima ora
passano da 10 milioni
a 9 milioni 954 mila.
Quando poi, alla fine,
e ce ne sono tante di azioni da fare,
partendo proprio dal nostro comportamento
di consumo,
che deve essere
solo un po più consapevole
solo un po più responsabile,
niente di più!
Non è che dobbiamo ridurre i consumi.
Io l'ho chiamato "meta-consumo",
forse lo riduciamo della metà
forse anche un po' meno,
però nuove forme di consumo
nuovi prodotti.
Andiamo verso la sostenibilità,
verso la localizzazione.
Modificando, in realtà,
le nostre abitudini un po' in meglio
per stare tutti bene, anche gli altri,
quelli che ci stanno vicino.
E poi, quando nel 2025 avremo finalmente
ridotto a metà lo spreco,
saremo a metà strada
ci vorranno forse altri anni
ma lo ridurremo.
E quando lo avremo ridotto del tutto
noi all'Università di Bologna
chiuderemo questo spin-off
e ci inventeremo qualcos'altro da fare.
Sicuramente nuove idee.
Grazie per avermi ascoltato.
(ApplausI)